like will you that Hey Oh sh t oh my god
I'm tackling a little bit of a phobia
today I've never worn heels before I
like heels on women oh they're sexy I
feel like there's a pressure on gay
people that they're supposed to be able
to wear them without fail I'm excited to
strut I mean I'm sure I'll look nice and
sexy make it happen
this is started terrified these are
weapons this is like a toothpick this
thing is for sure gonna break I'm just
gonna go for it
that's giving me anxiety oh god it's
already bad already feeling sexier one
two three oh oh me this is the worst I
don't like this oh my god I can't stand
straight I can't I can't stand because
I'm afraid that I'll fall oh okay ah
here we go oh this is pain city over
here it's like walking for the first
time jeez I'm like pushing 69 right now
I feel sexy hold up let me strut let me
get this I'm just figuring out but if
you like swing your hips with it I like
you get more like distribute
distribution of weight props and models
I can walk in the straight line without
looking like a horse I kind of want to
get good at it you know oh I've got the
hang of it I like the sound that it
makes like a workout my muscle in my leg
is literally going like this they should
have these at the gym just some bros
like put on some heels and just walk and
that's like one set I'm sweating because
I'm working so hard like my calves like
look at that this is harder than
football practice for sure I feel a
little bit like a rock star though kind
of feels like you're like hiking or
something you step on a log by accident
but the log is always in your shoes my
feet are in mousetraps right now I
forgot that women have to wear these for
a whole day by the end of the day I
would want to cut off my feet I
understand why every woman I've ever met
once a foot rub imagine doing this trunk
I thought I'd be better at this but then
I was work Oh kind of almost like worth
it to just put them on just so you can
take them off later because it's gonna
feel amazing it was worse than I
expected I didn't think it was that hard
I actually I thought it was gonna be
harder I 5 X chicks do this all the time
I'm like a loss for words I already feel
like my calves are getting strengthened
next time I'm dancing with the chickens
like are you okay I would never ask you
to do this for me this has changed my
view on heals forever I'm never like if
I see a heal in the store I'm walking
the other way to all fabulous women and
Dragons out there I salute you this is
just hold on